[Musique]
oh
bonjour nouvelle édition du café
politique revue de presse de l'actualité
locale l'actualité nationale et
internationale
aussi aujourd'hui d'une manière assez
assez exceptionnel puisque nous
enregistrons cette émission mercredi
matin tout simplement le jour de la noce
du résultat des élections américaines
bonjour à nos trois invités bertrand
guillon le maire socialiste de magny les
hameaux conseiller communautaire de
saint quentin suzanne blanc vous êtes la
première adjointe républicain de
montigny-le-bretonneux conseillère
communautaire de 50 ans et puis bruno
milian bonjour également président du
modem 78 conseiller régional d'île de
france on avait forcément plusieurs
sujets à aborder ce qui avait été un
petit peu prévu on va revoir notre copie
en raison de l'actualité et avant de
creuser un peu plus le sujet votre
premier sentiment à l'annoncé de cette
victoire résultat des élections
américaines donald trump
bertrand la nuit a été longue
et le résultat est
on est un peu abasourdi derrière parce
que c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose à
quoi on voulait pas forcément s'attendre
même s'il y avait des signaux depuis
plusieurs tentes ont montré une
évolution
de lectorat prévoit là c'est un choix
indépendant des américains c'est leur
choix on n'a pas de leçon à donner bien
au contraire on a surtout à regarder
chez nous comment ça se passe et a
essayé de travailler tout soupçon pour
le bien-être des habitants parce qu'elle
la question qui se pose c'est
l'incidence que ça aura sur la politique
internationale et donc forcément ça aura
aussi une incidence pour nous français
mais la question c'est aussi de voir
comment les élections vont se dérouler
dans quelques mois pour la france
puisque les mêmes causes produisant les
mêmes effets et la situation
internationale étant ce qu'elle est on
verra ce que ça donnera pour les
élections françaises susanne blank votre
sentiment
moi j'ai pour coutume de répéter qu'il
ne faut jamais se fier aux sondages et
je sais pourquoi je le dis mais c'est
vrai que c'est quand même assez
hallucinant au delà de 5 tout comme le
dit bertrand guillon c'est vrai que nous
ne sommes pas le peuple américain ils
ont fait leur choix
pas vraiment à nous d'en juger
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas et au
delà de ça on va voir la suite c'est
'wait and see' là maintenant franchement
est ce qu'elle est ce que le donald tram
qui arrivait les deux pouces en l'air
etc va perdurer déjà tout à l'heure on
voyait bien que c'était un petit je
serai le président de tous les
américains ses toiles à un peu plus
calme qu'avaient ils suivre après sa
position vis-à-vis de l'europe de nous
en particulier on a bien vu qu'il
comprenait le break site parce que
pourtant c'est très loin et on est tout
petit ça ça va être très important et
puis au niveau international les
alliances qui auront nuit aussi
avec les russes et déjà dit non mais
voilà tout à fait à nos manuels ouais
moi cette victoire de donald trump elle
m'inspire une réflexion surtout c'est
que je pense que les américains ont
envoyé un signal fort en disant vous ne
nous écoutait pas assez en gros à
l'establishment et ça c'est la culture
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on en prenne
la mesure définitivement en europe en
france en particulier pour réaliser les
mêmes causes produiraient c'est la
culture c'est la culture internet on
avec internet et le flot d'informations
qui est distribué en permanence en
continu sans tri sans analyse comme ça
de l'information brute les gens
finalement prennent ce dont ils ont
envie ce qu'ils veulent entendre ce
qu'ils veulent comprendre et ce qu'ils
ont compris on le voit bien la montée
des populismes en europe le breakbeat en
angleterre maintenant l'élection de
donald trump pour moi c'est un peu la
montée des consciences politiques pas
forcément armé centraux d'éducation je
veux pas être donneur de leçons mais qui
prennent l'info brute et qui prennent ce
dont ils ont envie et surtout qu'ils
s'aperçoivent peut-être que
l'establishment leur ment depuis trop
longtemps et c'est un peu un coup de
balai ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
et ça peut avoir des conséquences
importantes où effectivement pour les
futures élections en europe en france en
allemagne notamment il va falloir qu'on
fasse attention à tout ça mais pour
faire le parallèle justement avec la
situation européenne et la situation
française on explique souvent aux gens
qu'il faut et ça va nous ramener à des
sujets d'actualité ben non plus plus
nationaux qu'il faut voter contre il
fallait voter contre donald trump pas
forcément adhérer hillary clinton mais
il fallait voter contre donald trump en
france si on prend pas véritablement
raccourci mais on peut expliquer aussi
qu'il faut voter contre nicolas sarkozy
parce qu'il a déjà été président et que
il n'a pas il n'a pas été à la hauteur
selon selon certains des candidats il
faut voter contre françois hollande
puisqu'il n'a pas non plus rempli sa
mission
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il ya
pas de l'adhésion envers la classe
politique et personne qui incarne
vraiment des idées à un renouveau et là
je m'adresse à trois représentants de
trois formations différentes
je passe moi je pense que le prochain
président en dehors le prochain futur
président de la république française ou
la présidente faut pas l'exclure
maintenant
en dehors d'un programme de
réhabilitation de l'économie de
libération libéralisation d énergie qu
on respire un peu parce qu'on sent bien
qu'on a étouffé il va falloir qu'ils
nous proposent une vraie vision pour les
gérer les 20 ou 30 ans qui viennent moi
je trouve que dans les campagnes dans
les pré campagne parce qu'on est dans la
précampagne électorale on va être clair
je trouve qu'on ne parle pas assez par
exemple du monde de demain qui est en
train de se construire à côté de nous et
qu'on ne voit pas avec l'intelligence
artificielle par exemple il faut qu'on
en tienne compte parce que pour
l'instant on veut faire croire que
l'intelligence artificielle elle va
toucher uniquement les gens peu
qualifiés c'est pas vrai elle va toucher
aussi bien les ouvriers peu qualifiés
que le radiologue le plus confirmé donc
ça il faut qu'on arrive à y penser à
l'anticiper parce que ça va modifier
complètement notre structure sociétale
il va falloir qu'on propose quelque
chose aux gens on va avoir le choix
entre deux sociétés en gros une société
plus solidaire
il parce qu'il va falloir qu'on
s'entraide les uns les autres parce
qu'il y aura pas le choix parce que
pendant les 20 ans qui viennent ça va
être compliqué ça va être difficile
parce qu'on va commencer par détruire de
l'emploi là vous voyez je peux pas la
langue de bois je vous dis franchement
ce que je pense on va commencer par
détruire des emplois ça veut pas dire
qu'on entend recréer demain mais il va y
avoir une période d'adaptation qui va
être difficile donc il va falloir qu'on
faut penser à tout ça il faut vraiment
que nos politiques nous offre une vision
les gens parlent parlent du programme
nécessaire mais il faut quelqu'un pour
pour l'incarner aussi ce programme et il
n'y a pas de l'adhésion aujourd'hui même
en france autour d'un
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de modèle par
exemple au modem on explique aussi qu'il
faut voter alain juppé parce que surtout
il faut pas voter nicolas sarkozy alors
sache que je peux vous expliquer
pourquoi il ya pas de souci parce que je
pense que nous aujourd'hui on est rentré
dans un fait partie de notre adn nous on
prône le rassemblement depuis toujours
et depuis la création du modem et même
avant françois bayrou le porter mais
depuis la création du modem on prône le
rassemblement pourquoi parce que les
réformes structurelles qu'on a à faire
elles doivent avoir le plus large
assentiment des citoyens si vous si vous
ne vous gouvernez que pour un camp
contre l'autre vous allez jamais pouvoir
les faire les réformes structurelles et
aujourd'hui des candidats à la primaire
celui qui nous paraît le plus
rassembleur avec lequel on peut discuter
c'est alain juppé c'est pour ça qu'on le
soutient même plus nous amène rapidement
à parler de la primaire en france et
suzanne blanch françois fillon je
soutiens françois fillon depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs peu de nouveautés
je suis séguiniste ceci explique cela
d'une part mais ça explique aussi que le
sectarisme
n'existe pas dans l'esprit est là je te
rejoins bruno c'est vrai que là on ne
peut jamais gouverner tout seul 2 il
faut effectivement quelqu'un qui
rassemble et 3 il faut même avant tout
il faut quelqu'un qui est un bon
programme voilà je trouve que ce
renouveau même si j'ai j'entends doute
candidat dire que le renouveau ce sont
eux
sur le pire hier comme ça voilà
le renouveau c'est ça n'est pas le fait
d'avoir été enfin je veux dire ce que ce
qui est reproché à certains c'est
d'avoir été déjà ministre que cette
altitude tout le monde a été alors voilà
parmi les candidats à la primaire de la
droite bien sûr
mais au-delà de ça par mille
parmi ce qui est dans le programme
pardon de françois fillon c'est qu'il ya
quand même des choses tout à fait
innovante et qu'il faut oui donner
quelques coups de pied dans la
fourmilière mais sans pour autant dire
que tout va être dans le drame la
douleur etc c'est un peu ce que j'ai eu
déjà l'occasion de dire sur le plateau
et semaine dernière c'est pour préparer
effectivement le monde de nos enfants et
de nos petits-enfants et puis c'est vrai
il y aura des mesures difficiles à
prendre mais il faudra les prendre ça ne
veut pas dire tout supprimer ça veut
dire qu'on pense et ça veut dire faire
différemment mais en tout cas voilà
c'est en ce programme que je croyais en
ces termes que je crois bertrand oui on
peut l'écouter du parti socialiste
comment vous regardez cette primaire de
la droite sachant qu'ensuite il y aura
une primaire aussi à gauche et j'en
reviens aussi toujours à cette idée qui
me tient malgré tout du vote contre et
non pas du vote pour un candidat et
récemment par exemple benoît hamon
député des yvelines qui disait plutôt
hollande valls par exemple je suis né
dans les années 70 dub les années
soixante dix on a toujours les mêmes
personnes qui se présentent aux
élections présidentielles convoi dans
l'ensemble des ministères
alain juppé je vais toujours connu
nicolas sarkozy on l'a toujours vu
françois fillon pareil c'est pareil à
gauche
un moment on a un peu l'impression qu'il
y à aussi en france et il faut en
prendre conscience puisque c'est les
retours aussi qui nous souffrait des
habitants c'est clairement ce que je
pense aussi
une élite qui gouvernent qui se
remplacent
les uns les autres qui essayent de de
garder les places ou de récupérer des
places
on le voit dans la primaire à droite
avec nicolas sarkozy essaie de récupérer
une clope mais on le voit aussi on voit
aussi à gauche de manière de manière
générale à un moment donné on a un jeu
de chaises musicales qui s'autoalimente
est derrière avec l'impression pour les
françaises et les français que
on ne s'occupe plus d'eux
les premiers besoin c'est de pouvoir
manger
pouvoir dormir sous un toit pouvoir
s'habiller pouvoir avoir des loisirs
pour pouvoir vivre dignement avoir un
métier avoir un parcours professionnel
avoir un parcours pour sa famille à voir
l'éducation qu'on saison forme et
finalement quand on regarde depuis 30 40
ans
à part dire que
les pauvres c'est peut-être de leur
faute que
finalement il faut essayer de préserver
certains un moment forcément tout le
monde finit par se poser des questions
sur les personnes qui nous gouvernent
aujourd'hui
pour éviter d'avoir peut-être un coup de
balai hasardeuses trop hasardeuse et
certainement qui serait un vrai recul à
un vrai désastre pour une république
comme la france
il faudrait peut-être
commencer au lieu de se regarder le
nombril dans certains partis
rediscuter avec les gens c'est vrai la
guitare le parti social c'est valable
pour tous les interdits c'est valable
pour tout le monde alors là dessus je
suis pas je suis militant au parti
socialiste suis pas représentant de la
structure
chacun sa liberté de d'expression moi
j'ai la mienne et si ça plaît pas à
quelques changements klich le tout c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde comprenne
que
ce qui arrive pour l'année prochaine en
france
peut être un vrai désastre non pas pour
nationale c'est ça que la mangue vous
entre vous entendez par exemple ou ou
des populistes cacher
parce qu'à un moment donné ces discours
là
on les retrouve chez d'autres quand je
joue à la double ration frites un moment
donné faut arrêter
on est en france on est là pour habiter
ensemble cette fraternité qui doit nous
qui doit nous amener tous ensemble ça
peut paraître un grand mot mais c'est
juste essentiel il faut redonner des
couleurs à seif à cette fraternité il
faut redonner
du sens à ce mot il faut qu'il soit
compris par tout le monde et c'est
simplement la plus belle des protections
qu'on puisse avoir pour vivre dignement
nous et ça c'est pour moi juste
l'essentiel il ya un climat qui est
difficile actuellement on ne célèbre un
triste anniversaire 13 novembre les
attentats parisien celui du bataclan du
stade de france et des terrasses des
cafés également pas oublier ce qu'on
évoque souvent le bataclan mais on
oublie qu'il ya eu le même soir des
attentats aussi à d'autres comptes de la
capitale il ya ce climat-là sécuritaire
il ya la pauvreté qui est qui est à
travers toute l'europe et même au delà
avec la crise des migrants des réfugiés
et l'accueil qui est différent en
fonction des communes ce qui m'amène à
parler de la situation à maurepas par
exemple on a vu les élus se s'inquiéter
de l'arrivée de la réquisition à la
dernière minute 2 dans un gymnase
finalement c'est une salle des fêtes qui
a été réquisitionné pour une quinzaine
de jours suzanne blanch vous êtes du
même bord politique que cette commune là
vous avez peut-être échangé avec grégory
des restiez le maire sur cette question
bon tout cas quel est votre regard sur
cet accueil des migrants je sais que
pour eux c'était c'était compliqué moi
je crois que ce que je ressens presque
maurepas avait aussi accueilli des
réfugiés pendant l'été
mais l'été ce n'est pas la même période
c'est le cas de le dire
dans la mesure où les gymnases par
exemple sombres sont moins occupés bon
après il faut trouver la meilleure
solution ce qui à mon sens qu'il aurait
fallu tout de même c'est que
la moindre chose eût été que le préfet
discutent un petit peu avec le maire
voilà on n'en serait peut-être pas
arrivé à une démonstration de ce type et
voit montini par exemple est-ce que vous
avez des échanges réguliers avec la
préfecture sur un accueil probable
éventuelle de milan à ma connaissance
pour l'instant non l'essentiel c'est
qu'il est tout de même qu'ont promis de
trouver que c'est grâce à lui 30 à la
salle des fêtes évidemment parce qu'on
est là devant un drame tel que voilà on
peut on peut tout dire là dessus mais
c'est épouvantable enfin moi je sais que
parfois quand enfin je ne veux pas être
la seule mais quand on reste pauvres
gens et ces pauvres en france surtout
c'est surtout ça c'est pour vos enfants
eje voilà c'est juste pas possible on ne
peut pas rester là et on se doit de
faire quelque chose bien évidemment
comédienne votre positionnement sur
cette question de l'accueil des migrants
ouais mais chien moi mais mon sentiment
c'est que mon la démonstration de force
qui a été fait par les élus il fallait
non pas à maurepas oui ils ont été
acculés 1 ils ont été acculés très
sincèrement quand vous apprenez la
nouvelle la veille au soir 19h pour vous
organiser c'est compliqué d'autant qu'il
y avait une autre solution que le
gymnase après je ne sais pas si moi en
tant que maire de maurepas j'aurais eu
cette réaction là je n'aurai peut-être
une autre mais je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail moscou ce qu'ils ont bloqué
les bus voilà moi je veux simplement que
les gens aient conscience d'une chose
susan a commencé à le dire
les français ont peur des migrants
certes avec avec le climat sécuritaire
qui a depuis les attentats ça ça attiser
les peurs mais faut voir que les
réfugiés ceux qui viennent de syrie peut
aussi ont aussi peur que nous donc si
vous additionnez les peurs on va vers
une catastrophe ça c'est clair et si
j'en veux beaucoup à ce gouvernement qui
n'a pas su à travers les préfets de
faire la cartographie nécessaire qu'il
fallait faire des lieux possibles
d'accueil je prends simplement la région
parisienne il ya en termes de logement
alors évidemment il ya des logements
privés etc mais en termes de logement il
ya trois cent vingt mille logements
vacants en ile de france ne s'est pas en
train de chemin en train de dire à des
propriétaires privés ouvrez grand vos
appartements et laisser s'installer les
migrants mais c'est pour vous dire que
des logements ou des des points
d'accueil digne j'entends il y en a
parce que même la solution trouvée qui
est la salle des fêtes je suis désolé
c'est pas digne c'est pas digne ces gens
là il faut qu'on les accueille dignement
qu'on fasse qu'on fasse évidemment le
tri entre les réfugiés et les migrants
sont l'a déjà dit je me suis déjà
exprimé là dessus et puis il faut que
alors vous ne s'agira pas aussi vite
qu'on veut mais il faut vraiment que
l'europe se réveille quoi là dessus
parce que les le de savoir qui est
réfugié au quai migrants c'est aux
frontières de schengen qui faudrait que
ce soit fait et non pas quand il arrive
sur les territoires nationaux et malgré
tout on va relativiser les choses ces
trente à trente six mille migrants qu'on
nous demande d'accueillir nous sommes 60
6 millions de français donc si on fait
les choses bien comptablement ça doit
être faisable
bertrand guillon votre regard sur la
situation et sur l'accueil des migrants
peut-être même à saint quentin au delà
de ça et puis même question est ce qu'un
magny les hameaux par exemple la
question s'est posée avec la préfecture
d'abord c'est une responsabilité
citoyenne de tout le monde
c'est uniquement de l'humanité il faut
mettre de côté tout esprit partisan là
dedans je pense pas que de faire une
banderole s'apprennent juste quelques
heures et
[Musique]
j'ai vu une banderole se met devant
début ça mord pas chacun prend ses
responsabilités
ce que j'observe aujourd'hui à bord pas
c'est qu'ils sont avec lui dans un lieu
qui est pas forcément super adapté mais
autour il y a des habitants des citoyens
qui
qui aide qui accompagne qui font le
nécessaire la solidarité intercommunale
elles existent puisque par exemple celle
de la verrière qui a mis à disposition
des douches dans un gymnase
parce qu'à un moment donné un lieu où il
n'y a pas de douche pour passer quinze
jours c'est un peu compliqué et pour moi
c'est pas dit à magny les hameaux
on a proposé des initiatives depuis
longtemps qu'ils ne se sont pas mises en
place malheureusement et moi je le
regrette sur l'accueil chez l'habitant
suite aux sorties aussi des centres
d'hébergement on a cinq six familles qui
sont prêtes à accueillir d accueillir
des réfugiés et des migrants dans ce
cadre là sans problème
je veux juste savoir bertrand par quel
biais ces personnes sont arrivées à
manille elle ne vous ont pas été imposée
elles sont arrivées par le biais de
l'association
s'est imposée parce que derrière on n'a
pas été informé parce que ça s'est passé
aussi par le biais du 115 pour nous
puisque c'est pas dans le cadre des
réfugiés comme on a pu les voir par
exemple comme ils ont de
l'accompagnement à bonal je discute
beaucoup avec
avec ipou par le maire de gonesse sur
cet accompagnement justement qui est
fait dans une petite commune
des yvelines qui est un très bel exemple
de solidarité locale de soutien
par une commune qui est pas importante
en nombre d'habitants du coup au niveau
intercommunal des habitants ils sont
allés les habitants de ma commune des
habitants des communes alentours sont
partis les aider là bas nous à magny les
hameaux on a un équipement on a un lieu
en fait facile d'utilisation qui est un
lieu touristique à la base c'est sûr
alors il n'est pas question de prendre
la totalité du lieu
mais on a maintenant depuis depuis deux
trois ans assez régulièrement des des
personnes qui sont hébergés à cet
endroit là je me suis offusqué un moment
donné parce que ça donnait parfois
l'impression de
de faire du marchand de sommeil à
certaines occasions j'ai mis les pieds
dans le plat vis-à-vis la préfecture on
s'est expliqué ses revenus de manière de
manière correcte maintenant voilà j'ai
pas forcément l'information 2 qui arrive
etc
c'est dommage mais en même temps c'est
très compliqué pour pour les services de
la préfecture à gérer aussi puisqu'il ya
différents organismes qui qui
interviennent dans ce cadre là en tout
cas à chaque fois qu'ils viennent
non les accueillent on les accompagne et
ça se passe franchement très bien
d'ailleurs enfin il ya enfin on n'entend
pas parler en fait et pour refaire le
parallèle par rapport au discours de
donald trump pendant la campagne
franchement on n'a pas de leçon à donner
par rapport à ce qu'on entend nous en
france par rapport à tout ça compte
quand il explique les mexicains sont des
voleurs et des violeurs
quand on entend des discours on regarde
dans les médias ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans le 16e arrondissement de
paris les discours que j'entends mais
c'est c'est juste ignoble et tout ça
c'est notre responsabilité noir quand il
est lu d'accompagner d'arrêter de monter
les uns contre les autres les gens
d'arrêter avec ses habitudes là et de
repartir sur un chemin de de partage et
de et de construction ensemble partager
ce point de vue et puis après il va nous
rester quelques minutes d'émission est
vrai ce que j'allais dire je pense pas
que nous trois ici soyons des soignants
des personnes en qui en qui quoi que ce
soit on est plutôt des gens ouverts plus
tôt voilà si ici il ya un climat de peur
que vous évoquez qui a été créé dans
notre pays il est pas forcément dues aux
parties que vous représentez à celui qui
représente bruno et au maire je pense
qu'en tout cas la du climat de corps est
aussi un sentiment d'inquiétude parce
que les politiques mais pas forcément
répondu c'est que la réponse apportée à
ce que
vous parliez il ya trois secondes du 13
novembre c'est après demain
voilà bien évidemment qui à ce climat là
et bien évidemment qui donne entretenu
par un certain nombre de choses et
d'attitudes de certains faut quand même
le dire je large parle pas de politique
je parle tout simplement de de certaines
populations facile de trouver des boucs
émissaires
c'est trop facile que d'essayer de huy
de construire des choses et de trouver
des solutions même si on est dans des
temps qui sont très courts parce qu'à un
moment donné
voilà il ya de l'adaptation aussi à
trouver un meilleur juste revenir vivre
un point sur ce je regrette juste une
chose c'est qu'il ya eu un manque de
concertation on voit que dans certaines
dans certaines villes de france en
fonction la personnalité du maire les
choses se sont bien organisés avec le
préfet et dans d'autres endroits de
france où les mères sont moins connus
politiquement où ils sont moins sur le
devant de la scène les choses se font
été imposée voilà je regarde simplement
c'est ce manque de concertation parce
que je pense que s'il y avait une vraie
concertation on aurait pu aboutir à plus
de choses je vais pas encore vent de
françois bayrou mais à pau par exemple
il ya plus de 500 familles d'aujourd'hui
qui sont installés et disséminés dans la
ville et ça se passe très bien parce que
évidemment quand le préfet appelle
françois bayrou il va d'abord lui
demander ce qu'il en pense et comment il
peut faire les choses si l'appel bruno
miliana jumeaux vide le préfet il va me
dire voilà je te réquisitionne ça donc
séance la séance là où ou voilà je pense
qu'on aurait pu la guerre en syrie ça
fait quatre ans c'est le plus de quatre
ans et que on savait que ces gens là
donc on n'aurait pu le préparer je jette
pas le jeu jette pas la responsabilité
forcément sur ce gouvernement là je sais
pas comment un autre gouvernement réagit
ils ont plein de choses à traiter c'est
peut-être très compliqué mais malgré
tout aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se
passer des élus locaux c'est eux qui
connaissent leur territoire quatre ans
vous êtes le premier à l'avoir dit donc
il aurait fallu effectivement un peu
plus de concertation sarp révoqué - 1h58
peur de part et d'autre et donc plus
d'acceptation puisqu'on le voit bien là
où ça se fait bien là où ça se passe
bien il ya l'adhésion de la population
donc on a quand même une espèce
d'antagonisme entre l'adhésion de la
population une fois que les gens sont là
pour les aider et la crise que ça
provoque dans les médias autour en dix
ans et c'est pas normal machin etc les
gens sont prêts à aider les français
sont prêts à aider c'est l'inversé c'est
ça l'important oui oui mais il faut le
dire il faut aussi qu en haut on tienne
compte un petit peu d élus locaux je
suis juste désolé de le dire mais c'est
la base de tout coup voilà moi j'allais
dire le français râleurs sait mais il
est généreux par ailleurs donc moi je
désespère pas du tout
du genre humain et en particulier d'une
autre a franchement ça pourrait être la
conclusion de ce café politique passe
désespérée au regard de l'actualité bien
triste qui nous occupait au cours de
cette demi heure d'émission juste un
tour de table rapide sur ce que vous
retenez de l'actualité des quinze
derniers jours bruno myle yens et puis
on terminera avec mes romans il ya une
actualité voit la fragilité l'élection
d'aubry on en a déjà parlé moi moi ça
m'inquiète beaucoup pour ce qu'ils l'ont
de choc que ça risque de propager et je
suis j'ai qu'un message à un passé à nos
futurs candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
donnez nous une vision parce qu'il ya
plein de sujets dont on parle pas on
vient de parler des migrants par exemple
le réchauffement climatique ça n'a pas
fait que faire apparaître une jungle à
calais je suis désolé de le dire à
nicolas sarkozy mais ça je peux pas
entendre ce genre de choses le
réchauffement climatique l'environnement
la préservation la biodiversité par
exemple ça va être un des problèmes
auxquels on va être confronté demain et
en termes de migration ça va être un
flux cent fois mille fois cent fois ce
sont mille fois plus important que ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui à cause des guerres
il va peut-être falloir aussi qu'on
parle de ça mais on peut préciser que
donald trump n'a pas l'intention
d'appliquer les différents accords
internationaux en matière
d'environnement c'est fait partie de son
programme
suzanne blanch ce qui vous a marqué dans
l'actualité des quinze derniers jours
c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui tout est
balayé donc voilà sauf qu'aujourd'hui on
est tout de même le 9 novembre que c'est
c'est quand même une journée marquée de
plusieurs anniversaires la mort du
général de gaulle d'autres drames qu'ont
vécu qu'a vécu le genre humain
voilà donc c'est un peu curieux c'est un
peu curieux c'est
une drôle de soirée qu'il fallait garder
bertrand guillon
on est à un an d attente acrobat a cloué
à paris et
le bataclan va rouvrir
c'est une note d'espoir
puisque à partir du moment où il y a
cette fraternité en france
on sera toujours debout et
participe à un mouvement fort soutien au
mouvement qui s'est s'est créé et qui
s'appelle fraternité général en ce
moment ils ont décrit vidéo un petit peu
partout sur les chaînes de télévision et
et des événements qui ont lieu et et ce
message des artistes du monde de la
culture du sport
citoyens de manière générale associatif
c'est aussi tout c'est tout cet élan qui
doit nous permettre de sortir du marasme
dans lequel
on a parfois l'impression de trop tomber
merci à tous les trois prochains cafés
politiques le 26 novembre merci de nous
avoir suivis
[Musique]